so welcome everyone to chess in 21st
century so this is the lecture I
prepared last week but the Grantchester
happened so I'm going to be giving this
lecture today so I wanted to talk to
cover the games of a young player from
India his name is
I think pronounce program Nanda so he
just became the youngest I am at the age
of 10 years and 10 months of course on
track on become to become a very strong
player so I wanted to go over a couple
of weeks guarantee that is I am NOT so
recently so good I look at a couple of
his recent games so it's playing black
so this um he played in the oil field
open is there anyone familiar with this
tournament IRA float IRA float so IRA is
actually an Russian airline and they
have this very strong open in Russia and
to play in a group I think you have to
be over 2500 or 2550 fetus is very yeah
it's a very strong tournament so that
they have Group a group B group C I
believe group seized under 2300 Group B
is 23 to 2,500 so very strong tournament
I think they didn't have it for a couple
of years but now it's back so to play in
that tournament is you know great great
challenge great opportunity so it's
playing black so night of 396
so the tonight's opening of course a lot
of ways for white to play 95 is an
option d3 is an option so deform and
what should block do now so someone
taught you defy but they didn't teach
you white hits play d5 it's much more
important to understand your opening
that memorize your lines because if you
end up in a position that you don't know
and you don't remember then how you're
going to figure out a move we need to
understand why you're doing the things
you're doing
so first of all the knight doesn't have
too many good squares to go to and
second of all white is going to have a
strong center if you don't do anything
in the center so your opponent's playing
in the center so you have to strike in
the center so we're playing d5 for two
reasons so it's a temple move and we're
creating the space for our square for
our Knight
so the scary thing that looks what looks
scary is take take take
and now our King is stuck in the center
and the King side is compromised but
fortunately for us we haven't committed
to castle links so we still have the
opportunity to Castle queenside and we
have this very strong Center and we're
up upon you we have to count so if
castle Bishop e6 Queen out and I'm going
to cancel this side and I'm fine and of
course our King is not in trouble
because our opponent has not really had
in development and we were able to close
the e-file so you're playing d5 to make
safe square for your Knights because if
you play something like this and I go
Bishop d5 again your knight has to move
around so d5 the bishop has to go to b5
pinning bishop takes
so the reason that the bishop takes is
because if you take whoops it's because
if you take with the knight you're
losing another temple and the bishop is
going to get out so you're trying to
play against this compromised pawn
structure and also this night can be
kicked away and in some instances
doesn't have a very good place to go so
let's make a couple more moves so route
B it is not the most common move it
should be seven is more common so
White's idea is to play something like
okay oops so why did we go F three or
four instead of four right away
if I go f4 right away whose turn is it
whose turn is it blogs is not a trick
question okay so we should be sad but if
we do something like this now it's white
smoke so I actually gained a temple okay
so he played rugby eight so repeat the
idea is to make development of this
Bishop a little difficult but at the
same time black is not quick enough to
develop his King side and castle so an
IP dream it should be three attacking
the pawn so we're white lost the temple
now he's going to gain a temple back he
moved his Knight away from the center
but now he's gaining the temple temple
back by attacking this pawn
so a 692 and f6 so what do we think
about a move like this
right
yeah so it's very understandable why why
my blog wants to do something like this
because if let's say black castles so
black has to do something in the center
because I've doesn't compare doesn't
want me to play four so I'm just making
random moves for black just to show if
this plot if this pawn comes all the way
to f6 this King has some problems so
black has to react to this F pawn push
somehow but he played f6 in this
position so obviously trying to open up
his bishops open up his position but
what can possibly be wrong with playing
f6 orally right
King is in the center and black
voluntarily is opening the center and we
know the general rule is if your king is
in the center you tried to keep the
center closed until your castle then
your king is a way so you don't play
where your king is your opponent plays
where your king is so how can we
possibly take advantage of this King so
we have to take to open up the well he
didn't take but so if you play something
rook e1 I'm just going to cancel away so
hard to make wookie one a temple move it
sounds so fun to a lot of things so what
are the good pieces for both colors and
bad pieces
so what pieces does white want off the
board
exactly so yeah if we have the same
position if I take out these two pieces
besides the fact that the King is going
to be much weaker this dark squares will
be very weak so if I can put a knight on
c5 as I mentioned goodnight versus a bad
Bishop blacks position is going to be
very tough and this bishop is going to
be charged and this bishop is already
bad because of this pawns so the bishop
wants to get out to f5 and find some
activity and both of these funds are
very weak so Bishop c5 is possible of
course black is not going to make a move
like this on resign so black is just
simply going to play King here and do
artificial castling and then rook out so
it's going to take a few more moves but
black is surviving here so I like this
Bishop a7 move a lot because it's a
temple move so rotates to go somewhere
let's say b7 so now we're going to check
King f7 same artificial castling and now
how do we get a grip on the dark squares
yeah there should be four
so we're defending this pawn 95 is going
to be a temple move
so even malthus's so here queen FY Queen
f6 is not possible
actually even in your losing material
but this position is already very bad
for the same reason so in addition we
also have this King safety problem but
let's say you're surviving with your
King I put a knight here complete of
complete domination of the dark squares
and this Bishop is just terrible
weakness weakness bad piece and the
knight is on a dark square so this
Bishop can never capture it so tonight
is just going to be here
so in stats he played Bishop d4 take
take
Quincy 3 defending and now g7 mmm
but let's do an overall so blood kind of
got away with his blood bad place so he
could have been a much in a much worse
position so now the question is how
important is this pawn and what's blocks
idea and what does black want his pieces
to be so someone mentioned another move
so let's see so why do you want to play
the role cone before right so here black
is playing for initiative so because if
black plays something passive like ruby
795 then what goes to a said one it's
very you know your pieces are very
passive and you're not really using your
to Bishop advantage so for your two
bishops to be strong you need to push c5
d for c4 for this Bishop to come into
your game so route before is a very good
move because you're training rook g4 and
you're getting all of this
Bishop c7 nasty threat so white takes
where to go Quincy eight the bishop back
so while it would put the rock down to
four so Quinn goes to c3
so we gave up a pawn so again we're
playing for initiative so we have to
play active so we don't want black for
the one way to get a grip on the dark
squares so how do we stop like from
playing 54 or 95 yeah see 5 yourself so
where is blocks compensation
so two bishops
what else
so active pieces active row Pierrot
country four is very nice so this rook
lifts ideas are one of my favorite ideas
in chess in general so what else
right so the center is moving so some
King side attack ideas
what about pieces what is a bad piece
for white yeah so the knight on v3 is
very bad when the pawn was on c6 this
night was great because it's not wanting
to go to c5 and control everything once
we push here this Knight is actually
quite bad so the bishop on e5 is of
course great but this night is terrible
so f3 so we go back so Queen a5 so here
actually black has a nice tactic but a
little bit complicated so what's the
first move we have to look at here mmm
so c4 inviting your opponent's piece
into the game oh crap oh okay yeah right
yeah roped you to I don't think you're
ready for it whoops you two yet because
you're parenting your pieces are really
coming in so you have Bishop h3 but you
don't have a follow up yeah a bit okay
very enough
so yeah so Roku to the rub CT doesn't
work so Bishop h3 looks very natural to
me so we have to calculate what happens
after Bishop h3 so in the game we played
Bishop date so but so after rook F 2
where it has a black has a very nice
tactic c4 Knight d4 my knight is going
to be great in the center so you don't
want to play c4 here unless you have a
very specific reason because c5 fun is
keeping my night away rook takes after
him
jeetu so I cannot go here I have to go
here
huh
cringy for they have mate yes
apply soap or you want to play queen g4
instead so you're threatening my rogue
and you're threatening luggage - yeah
can I stop this I'll rock you - you're
just going to take mmm
rock you three I'm going to take mom to
three and then going after is coming
okay let's deliver way of stopping this
doesn't look like it
yeah so white can define with Bishop d3
here I suppose so Bishop III why didn't
I consider this movement analyzing this
looks good so he played a sneaky move
you play Bishop d8 so of course they
cannot take so Queen goes back so what
to do now but also so you want to go
here here so we should be fine
I don't know I'm starting to like this
position so here here take it away or
something like this so you're a Tigers
just instead of c64
oh I say okay so d4 c3 there should be
five so you want to play here I think
it's a nice square yeah so I mean one of
your advantages that block has is this
initiative in this to a bishop and maybe
I can't even play the rookie one and not
to give you all that but the question is
we want the bishop on e6 or c6 so he
doesn't want to commit with his pawns
yet because the past you are nice so we
definitely don't want to play c4 so
which way is better to go
so I mean there's an immediate problem
with this but at the same time if you
put a bishop on e6 you also still
keeping in mind this ideas of Bishop h3
because on c6 this diagonal is closed
but for me 6 you have choices
so King h1 so deform 75
so here we played a move but there's a
better continuation
so what to do
your vision so that's when he played but
there's a better continuation actually
what's blacks worst piece
you should one do it so now that the
pawn structure has changed we can this
Bishop go right because we have this
pawn chain so bishop on g5 now just
simply threatening to put a bishop on it
to read and it's going to become very
hard for y to find moves and then I can
come off the decision so of course
playing a move like f4 is just
terrifying because probably can even
sacrifice and take everything so you
played Queen f5 with one pack now he
plays here it should be three
so we can go over to the edge file and
now 95 so now block to move
let's go back so what is what is the
threat
what is blogs big threat right and this
is this happens because this queen is
over words protecting everything and we
know that one piece just can't do
anything so just to make a random move
we want to take take and win a piece so
the piece run away oops
so Knight takes to block to move so now
all like literally every single one of
your pieces is aiming at the king so now
this is a very good time to look for
tactics alright so the king is in it in
a checkmate so if you can check on the
diagonal it's going to be made so okay
so we don't want to give up our bishop
because there's the piece that's going
to be checked mating so rook takes so
how do we take with the Queen
yeah because we don't care about the
Queenie for checkmating and if you take
with the bishop you if you take with the
bishop you actually don't have a threat
not really threatening anything so with
the Queen with threatening mate so what
is why it's only move
mm-hmm and now so if rook takes g3
what's your move after she takes f3 so
let's say this is your game how you're
going to take on g3 or are you going to
take on to 323 so why queen my queen
takes g3 actually gives you opponent the
list amount of options and it's less
work so it's very encouraging to make
news like this so you still have the g2
threat so this is mate and why it just
simply doesn't have any moves okay rook
takes two three as possible but so if I
take with the coin you'll take with the
rook but I have this and if you take
with the rock I'm going to play here
and then yeah but game continues so
pointy three very nice tactic so I
thought he played this game really well
I like I really like this route before
move so very nice move sacrificing and
then I like how he continued to just
like because here when he gives up the
pawn it's a long-term compensation so he
doesn't have to do something crazy to
prove that he gave up upon for a reason
so long-term his pieces are good that
snotty star of the game he's building up
an attack so he has a time to do
something so White's pieces are kind of
scattered
so this Bishop only five is nice but
it's alone
there's no pieces supporting it and it's
aiming aiming here but this square is
defended and this Queen is out of the
game this Knight is just completely
useless so at some point in the game
white white should have tried to play c3
and break apart this pawn chain but he
played too slowly and what black simply
just done improved all his pieces
without like hit anyone he didn't do
anything fancy until the lot very last
part of the game like everything here is
just simply improving pieces and putting
every piece on its ideal square okay so
we have one more game from him flip this
one so here is white say 45 so deterring
does anyone play this for white or black
for white or black both oh really okay
so which which move do you like facing
the list with block before but now you
know how how do you Candice win the game
but in that game I have to say he played
the opening very carelessly so you could
have just been in trouble out of the
opening so like you play like a
ten-year-old basically you know it's
like pushing fonts and not cancelling so
you don't mind 95 no so I'm asking you
don't mind facing it no okay fair enough
actually I yeah when I played this I
usually play d3 because I like the
solutions so Bishop c5 transposing so
now transpose to an Italian game
substitute as I used to play this
position a lot with white and my coach
convinced me to start playing real Lopez
and the reason I like playing is this
opening is because white idea is so like
straight forward and so you just want to
play Knight f1 put a queen here in IG 3
H 4 and just check my dear upon and then
it's just it was like direct
one-dimensional kind of just but now I
have to play complicated openings so it
takes so usually here I would never take
out all this go 22 so it takes takes
here tonight f1 I don't want to spend
too much time on the opening so Quinn
back take so hard to take but okay so
this is not like right or wrong it's
like you take mom way to your have a + /
- you take the other way it's position
is equal they're both playable so like
which one would you choose
quintics looks kind of unnatural to
matting either have to take with the
knight or with a knight of the pond and
maybe can even take with the Queen
attack the pawn possible
so how many want to take with the pawn
two people so why do you want to take
with the pawn so like what is the
general rule when we have positions like
this like how do we decide
hmm let's say your rook was on f1 how
would you take so we're not thinking
right because you're opening your file
so generally when you have moved your
rook already so it makes a lot of sense
for black to capture it because kind of
discourages to take with the pawn
because there's you can't even play rook
f1 in one move because there's a knight
there but because the nature of the
position is kind of close there isn't a
lot happening White has the time to
rearrange his pieces so I think taking
either way is fine but he took with the
pawn and I think it's very interesting
because now I can move the knight put a
rock on f1 and I have an open file
because even on the e-file this rook is
attacking the pawn but I can defend the
pawn quite easily by moving my bishop so
doesn't seem to have a lot of future and
why species are kind of cramped so black
has a better center of the a 5-pound
which is a d3 pawn and this one is a
weakness so yeah so now you have a lot
of plans you can move your knight but
play rook at fun you can play d4 mmm so
rook d8
um
so night comes out
here so he played so the reason he
played so of course 93 to activate the
night control d4 so queen f2 because if
you're going to play d4 you need to get
out of this file twenty six two six and
before so how to continue
so anyone who plays if if for like faces
this woodblock or if you're an Italian a
royal Lopez player with white you need
really this move really needs to stand
out to you well okay you have a thread
so okay to you on centralizing move but
something so you could have played rugby
wand like you can always put your rook
on the one but there's something very
specific about this before so you're
attacking this you're putting pressure
on this e5 pawn right so what are the
defenders Knight Queen so if you can
somehow put more pressure on the
defenders so I agree the bishop wants
you to of course nice piece attacking
but it and realistically it's not really
doing much because you're attacking but
everything is defended if the knight
wasn't here then okay right and again if
you're and this is a theme in the rule
office so sometimes you go like a far a
four a five to go a four like before a
five just so you can put a bishop on a
four
so now Bishop is here so now we have a
threat so we're threatening this guy so
takes
so how do we take
so normally we would take with the sip
ones but here white has a very specific
idea again involving this sky so if
you're going to take with the line you
need to have an idea otherwise why
you're weakening your position so
normally we're going to take with either
pond too so she takes the floor looks
very nice because we've an open file we
want to play e4 it takes d4 we're
opening up the e-file and we have a pawn
chain so what happens if Knight takes
like while you're doing this besides the
fact that I'm giving you hints yes
exactly
again you only doing it because you have
a specific reason if you don't have if
you don't have this Knight f5 ideas 94
is just a terrible move because you're
just weakening your position so 94 we
should be seven hmm so which Knight
yeah so you can do it too so so he wants
to have both nights being able to have
access to this at five square
so again specific calculations tonight
here and another reason is if you do it
this way the Queen cannot stay on this
diagonal to stop 23 so the Queen is to
defend the bishop so Queen went here so
next move should be obvious 23
threatening mate and another problem for
black is if the pi is on h6
so both of these pawns are target's if
the pawn was on h7 I would simply just
play g6 maybe still will be under attack
but now wouldn't be hanging Atlas yes
hmm tonight is 5
I think the reason is playing Queen g3
is because he wants to provoke g6 and
have more weaknesses so his queen can
get in because here if you take let's
say I have to decide where so I cannot
go here because this thing so it looks
like more or less my position looks kind
of kind of together but if you also put
a pawn on g6 and my queen can get into
the dark squares but 96 is a good move
hmm so Queen g3 at h5
so taking right
so so Quincy for now we're taking so
King g7 so what to do so you decided to
bring another piece into the attack so
which piece can join the attack okay fun
so now I have a threat Knight h6 and
another one so of course if you're
attacking the more pieces coming to the
attack the more powerful your attack is
so block defense now what starts to play
simple
so block has no threads so we don't have
to be in a rush even simpler
there's something under it tick yeah
just take the point so now you're up to
pawn so if your attack doesn't work out
so if your attack doesn't work out you
can winning an endgame with two extra
pawns so rookie four so Queen has to go
we have to keep the pin
so check that comes here
um
to simply defense the pond now the other
night wants to go to a five this one is
hanging so here
Kingi
yeah so blog just wandered so I mean
okay so black player is a grandmaster
but when you're under pressure the whole
game it's especially in a position like
this when I wait like all these pieces
are coming games struggling to find most
very easy to just collapse and blunder
and this is how blunders happen right I
mean okay they can happen randomly to
like you just don't see something but
when you're under a lot of pressure the
whole game it's very easy to just give
something up and blunder so yeah so
sorry I went by too fast so take and of
course Knight f6 swinging a piece so
black resigned it's just a show so a few
interesting things I just want to go
over again then I liked in this game one
of the things ideas that I like is this
F takes c3 so again this kind of goes
against the general ideas that we know
because your rook moved away it doesn't
make sense to do it and especially you
have a rook on you one so you're closing
the file of your rook but White has a
long term idea bringing the rock back
and playing before in the future and
another thing is and I've talked about
this a lot in my lectures in general you
always want to keep an open mind and not
be too focused on white side one side of
the game because now you played before
now all the sudden something happens on
this side of the board so you put a
bishop on a four and now this is a
problem this F five square is a problem
as we saw so you always want to make
sure you're not to focus on one thing in
the game so you're looking at the hole
you're looking at the board as one so
you always want to keep an eye on
everything that's happening so this part
and the third thing that was interesting
so 94 again kind of an ugly move
creating this weakness and yeah just
kind of counterintuitive of how we learn
how we're supposed to capture in this
kind of positions but it's done for a
specific reason so if you have a
specific reason for making a weakness
and you calculate it's going to work out
then you can quite in play but if you
play 94 because you think this is the
best way to capture without this
tactical calculation then you know your
intuition is not there and
you need to pay attention to this kind
of things and the rest of the game is
just very straightforward just winning
the pawns so winning all the puns so
these are the two games that I have four
so we'll see how his career turns out
that he's ten years old and already and
I am